maybe my favorite moment from the entire
State of the Union yesterday was
when Senator Mitt Romney a republican
had a conversation with lying Republican
Congressman George Santos it was
seemingly tense after the fact Mitt
Romney was asked what was that all about
and Romney says I told Santos you don't
belong here Romney listen not not a guy
I voted for in 2012 but uh
good for him for saying this to George
Santos check this out
I didn't expect that he'd be standing
there trying to shake hands with every
senator in the president United States
investigation he should be sitting in
the back road staying quiet
in front of the president and uh
and people coming into the room
by the way I have to tell you many
elected officials in these situations
they walk super fast and it makes the
reporters have to Sprint and blah blah
blah look at Romney respectfully walking
slowly in order to allow the reporters
to do their job you got to commend the
guy for it he said he says he you know
that he embellished his record look
embellishing is saying you've got an A
when you get an A minus
you graduated from a college you didn't
even attend and you shouldn't be in
Congress and they're going to go through
the process and hopefully get him out
and uh but he shouldn't be there and if
he had any shame at all he wouldn't be
there right why did you make a point to
say that though I mean I mean it was
kind of out of your way he was standing
right there in the aisle shaking hands
with everybody did he respond to you uh
he may have I didn't hear it
man this is just absolutely the best and
John Boy did a sort of attempt at lip
reading what went on let's just listen
to a little bit of it I would have given
a lot to be sitting right there between
the two of these guys my Twitter just
absolutely blew up from this lip reading
so I'll try and dive into it a little
bit everyone's kind of figured out what
what Romney is saying he comes in on the
bottom right he says you ought to be
embarrassed
you ought to be embarrassed
ought to be embarrassed you got to be
embarrassed you gotta be it's saying you
got to be embarrassed and he's just
saying I should be
I should be
and then I don't know what he says here
I actually don't know what Romney says
because it looks like
anyway so then they go back and forth
fourth looking at this like it's the
Zapruder film good for Mitt Romney I
don't have much other commentary other
than good for Mitt Romney we've got to
keep the pressure up on George Anthony
Santos de volder some people wrote to me
and said you shouldn't include Katara
because there's really nothing lying
about being a drag queen although he did
lie about whether he was a drag queen
but you maybe don't include Katara so
anyway George Anthony devolder Santos he
shouldn't be there and we've got to keep
the pressure up so that uh he maybe will
resign I I think the the window may be
closing on that but absolutely nice job
by Mitt Romney so big picture Joe Biden
good speech uh triggering Republicans
overtly Sarah Huckabee Sanders
disgusting response and Mitt Romney best
sort of uh uh I guess we would call it
ancillary moment
um at the event and we will have all of
these clips for you on our Instagram at
davidpackman show and on our YouTube
channel at youtube.com slash the David
Pacman show
one of our sponsors today is zipx
nicotine toothpicks zipx brings you a
convenient alternative to smoking and
vaping and The Vape clouds the ashtrays
the thing in your lip that people can
see I've seen that around this is an
easier and less messy way to curb the
cravings and you can use zipx just about
anywhere zipx is available in six
flavors with two or three milligram
strength the nicotine and the flavor are
long lasting and zipx has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and
they are bad habits zipx toothpicks are
FDA registered their customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipx 2 picks you can only
get zipx online go to zipxtoothpix.com
and get 10 off with the code Pacman the
link is down below